la Cour suprême a déterminé que
l'inscription obligatoire et à
perpétuité de personnes reconnues
coupables de crime sexuel ou registre
des délinquants sexuels portaient
atteinte au droit à la liberté garantie
par la Charte dans un jugement rendu à 5
contre 4 les magistrats affirment que
l'inscription ou registre a de graves
répercussions sur la liberté de
circulation et la liberté de faire des
choix de personnes qui ne représentent
pas un risque accru de récidive au cours
de leur vie
le plus haut tribunal du pays donne donc
raison au plaignant un homme de
l'Alberta reconnu coupable en 2015 de
deux chefs d'accusation d'agression
sexuelle commises en 2011 à l'époque la
juge de première instance s'écrivait
dans sa décision que le risque de
récidive de l'homme était peu probable
mais en vertu de la loi il devait
néanmoins être inscrit au registre des
délinquants sexuels une obligation de
prendre à considération la situation
individuelle de la personne Jean-Claude
Bernheim expert en criminologie et
défenseur des droits des détenus partage
la vie du tribunal il est inexact de
dire que tous les délais transsexuels
présentent un risque accru de récidive
si on veut que le cette notion de
réhabilitation de réintégration sociale
puisse être réellement appliqué il faut
que la façon dont la gestion des des
condamnations soient faites à partir des
de la situation individuelle de chaque
personne est une femme aujourd'hui je me
sentirais peut-être
la sécurité que avant que la décision
l'automne le sénateur doit venu dont la
fille a été assassinée en 2002 par un
délai conceptuel récidiviste se demande
qui déterminera les critères
d'inscription
régisse pour les prédateurs récidivistes
surtout les prédateurs d'enfants il faut
que l'inscription soit obligatoire je
pense que ce qu'il faut laisser
maintenant au juge c'est la durée de
cette inscription là en enlevant la
notion de perpétue perpétuité le
gouvernement a un an pour réécrire la
loi avant que l'inscription obligatoire
au registre soit invalidée cependant les
inscriptions à perpétuité au registre
des délinquants sexuels sont maintenant
impossibles dans une déclaration le
ministre de la Justice dit demeurer
engagé à donner aux forces policières
tous les outils nécessaires pour
prévenir et enquêter sur les crimes
sexuels ici Valérie Michaela
Ottawa